we're back with anthony anderson and his
mama doris who i'm now just calling mama
um and you can see them every week on to
tell the truth
which is such an awesome show and we
thought it'd be fun
um to play our own version here of the
game
this one's called to tell the truth
all right i'm with that okay so we're
gonna meet three people
but only one of them um has sworn to
tell the truth and we'll ask them
questions and then try to decide who is
telling
the truth all right let's meet them
hello i'm a dog surf instructor
i'm a dog surf instructor
all right i am a dog surf instructor
um you got the hair for it okay anthony
i was just thinking the same thing like
i
i could see a reason that everybody but
yes sir
um you fit a fantasy bill in my mind
um welcome to the show okay here's a
little bit about our surf instructor
in their own words when i found myself
without a job and time on my hands i
started surfing i had the skills to ride
the waves and teach others how to
balance on the board too and soon
i was helping fidos and rovers ride up
and down the coast and it turns out even
with four legs you can still
hang ten i like that that's super cute
um okay anthony you're the master of
this game you
teach me how do you ask the first
question uh you just you just asked the
first ques uh question
uh uh you just go for it number one uh
what beach do you teach
uh dog surfing uh so i mainly teach on
huntington dog beach
great very dog friendly
number two same question yeah
dog friendly beaches huntington beach
number three let me guess dog friendly
beach
huntington beach yeah huntington
southern california baby
okay mom asked me a question you took it
out of my mouth
how long you been doing it number three
i've been surfing for 10 years but for
the past three i just started teaching
dogs
what about you number two yeah it's been
about three years
teaching dogs how to surf number one
youtube
i've been teaching dog sister for about
three years i've been surfing
for maybe 10 to 12. hmm
all of you guys are born how much money
do you
make number three uh it depends on the
client really
um some celebrity clients i'm not going
to name drop but
it depends on the dog at um i'd say
about
we run about a 75 an hour so uh
i say about 300 a day drew do you have a
question that you want to ask him
okay yeah i'll take a turn um okay
why did you start doing this number one
um so i started doing this because i've
been surfing since i was a little kid
i learned from my best friend who's from
hawaii
and i just thought why not combine it
with my love of dogs
i've always been a great animal advocate
so i combined
my love of surf and my love of dogs dog
surf instructor
okay i don't believe i don't believe
number one either mama uh-huh
number two why did you start doing this
well it's my love for dogs um and my
passion for surfing
um and rescuing a dog and
i left to surf i'm with my mama
y'all are boring i said
the same thing all right true right now
drew right now is where the music would
start to play and the lights would
change and we'd have to try to figure
out
who was lying we think all three of them
thank you anthony okay it is time to
decide who is telling the truth all
right we're gonna write down
um who you think is the real dog
surf instructor i have the best pen on
the planet
the biggest pen ever
okay it can't be three okay
all
they got him out of central casting all
right i got our answer we got our
answers
all right i'm ready are you ready mama
you go first and you tell me
all right you were born ready all right
you're first
who do you think is the real dog surf
instructor
the first liar is number one
number one for my mom okay anthony who
did you choose
uh i went with number one as well
i i didn't believe any of them uh but i
believe
number one the most out of all three so
i'm going with number one number one
drew who did you pick i believed number
one at
first but then because you all
guys did give the same answer it was
hard to decipher
but i'm going with number two number two
will the real
dog surfer please raise your hand
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i thought it was you that's cute yeah
i i at the very first question
i was like oh number one's very
convincing and then you guys all started
giving the same answers and i just had
to deduce it
based on total vibe what is your name
number two
my name's jill nakano jill nakano
you look cool and i was like it's jill
it's number two so i'm good hey you know
what
anthony i may suck at doing the game but
apparently i don't suck at the game
hey so this is what we're going to do
drew when we go back into production
again
you have to come on and be on our panel
oh joe you're a loving girl so much fun
i'll totally come and play that would be
a ball
and i feel more confident now thank you
jill and thank you
so much um number one and number three
for playing with us
um lindsay jill and rex i do really
appreciate your time
and um i just want to thank anthony
and mama mama doris who's now just mama
to me um i want to thank you so much for
coming on the show
and you can watch to tell the truth
tuesday nights on abc
and for more information about get real
with diabetes the whole campaign please
go to the drewberrymareshow.com so we
can point you in the right direction
of everything that doris and anthony are
doing
[Music]
you